you dos et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve parce que j'ai une avance à
vous faire ça fait super longtemps que
j'attends ça le site quizy pierre fr
bien fr twizy point fr mais [ __ ] c'est
pas possible
ce stress bordel coup dur pour les fiers
vient d'ouvrir alors en vrai on avait
déjà fin s'est excusé pouvait faire mais
j'avais annoncé nulle part tant il était
dégueulasse mais celui là il est tout
beau tout propre alors dessus vous
pourrez retrouver toutes mes vidéos bien
sûr dans l'onglet vidéo
et oui génie pourra se faire quelques
string delonglée stream mais je n'y ai
enfin ce dont je suis le plus content la
partie boutique du cidre la plainte
hicheur basé sur les vidéos il ya par
exemple le bas la girafe à la seule
l'unique la vraie la girafe forever et
vous faites pas ça si vous l'avez un
plat si je vais me retirer direct du
site y en a aussi un sur la position
foetale en cas de danger police sur pet
allons la brûler les tout froissé tous
les légumes et moi il faut que je
repasse mais vous savez le repassage
gros mais c'est très demandeurs voilà
moi j'adore présenter des tricheurs
froid c'est plein de poils de chat ça me
plaît beaucoup je suis très content
parce que la boutique des mushers qu'on
avait sorti à quelques années vous avez
su faire plus sauf que malheureusement
c'était sûr spreadshirt et la qualité
des t-shirts et dégueulasse tu fais trop
lavage et du sens plus de sûreté déjà au
bout de sa vie ce qui est un peu moyen
l'occident tir squeeze blanc je me suis
pas mal donné pour les dizaines vous
plaît cyprien validé d'ailleurs puisque
l'huile est un petit peu de talent dans
le dans le crayon à bon droit que moi je
moi je suis oeuvres d'art mais bon il
est quand même un peu fort là aussi
disponibles au bordeaux et chez pas je
trouve ça super cool d'avoir des
bouddhistes basé sur l'univers qu'on a
créé tous ensemble ça me fait vraiment
kiffé donc j'espère s'offre à qui fait
aussi parce que vous avez été très
nombreux à m'envoyer un mail en me
demandant où est passée la boutique des
horreurs tout cas c'est scandaleux a
remboursé oui mais elle n'est pas
disponible donc tu n'as encore rien
acheté en bourse et voilà ça fait tout
drôle de vous monter tout ça alors ça
fait des mois qu'on est dessus et qu'on
attend la sortie de ce [ __ ] de sites
il est là enfin slate.fr hashtags
lille.fr lol squeeze le site est tirée
du bas enfin ben voilà le site et là je
vais vous en dire plus pour vous les
services même de surprises et de plaisir
en découvrant le site le lien et tout
temps la description vous avez juste à
cliquer tu remontes et ton nom c'est
faux dans la description vous vous
retrouverez dessus j'espère que ça vous
fait plaisir moi [ __ ] je suis tout ému
je suis moustier je suis squeeze mis une
fois de plus soit jamais partagé de
montpensier intense toi et moi et aussi
pour vous dire de faire attention à ces
[ __ ] de fake dans les commentaires
youtube qui font défaut compte en fait
on dirait vraiment que c'est mon compte
et qui publient des liens qui en fait
sont des virus ne cliquez jamais là
dessus ce n'est pas moi même sur les
autres youtube heures imaginées sur leur
chaîne si vous voyez ça c'est du four ne
cliquez jamais là-dessus bordel si vous
devez cliquer sur un lien peu importe
sur la chaîne que cc squyres point fr ok
je suis un dictateur de la paire mais
bordel tout va disparaître comme comme
boutiques ferment tout doit disparaître
et j'en profite une fois de plus pour
vous dire merci merci de me faire marrer
dans les commentaires sur twitter sur
facebook par toulouse
super géniaux grâce à vous je vis de ma
passion juif parce que je joue à mes
jeux préférés en vidéo voilà grâce à ça
je peux vivre ce que ma c'est incroyable
c'est baba sall typique des merci merci
beaucoup c'est grâce à vous et puis
j'espère que les vidéos pour vous plaire
encore longtemps écouté
pour ma part je vous tiens au courant si
j'ai d'autres projets comme ça qu'ils
sortent il y avait eu l'appui va ya six
mois et la yassa et ben voila je crois
que j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
n'oubliez pas d'acheter le t-shirt
surtout legarda gueule [ __ ] vous êtes
géniaux et puis on se retourne bientôt
une prochaine vidéo chat monde pis merci
pour tout